Незвична тиша і незвично порожні, як для лікарні, коридори.
Через епідемію коронавірусу лікар-невропатолог Руслан Валько
разом з колегами має значно менше роботи, ніж зазвичай.
До лікарні можуть потрапити лише пацієнти в гострому стані, яких привозить швидка.
Усі планові операції, консультації і лікування скасовані.
Відповідно, лікарі не можуть повноцінно працювати так,
як передбачає другий етап медичної реформи, -
фінансуючись не з місцевого бюджету, а з бюджету Національної служби здоров’я,
яка оплачує лікарням медичні послуги відповідно до кількості пролікованих пацієнтів.
Гроші за пацієнтом, як і сама медреформа
в 15-ту лікарню Києва поки не дійшли, кажуть її лікарі.
Поки другий етап повноцінно не ввійшов. Тому поки особливо нічого… Поки карантин.
Руслан Валько та його колеги не приховують розчарування.
Вони дуже чекали, коли ж в країні розпочнуться глобальні зміни в медицині.
Але наразі окрім неможливості повноцінної роботи під час епідемії,
в них немає і повного розуміння,
чи зможе їхня лікарня успішно працювати після завершення карантину.
Лікарів зовсім не влаштовують тарифи оплати їхніх послуг,
які, як вони кажуть, просто були спущені згори.
Чи зможемо ми в цю суму - 16 000 грн, які на інсульт виділяються,
так сказати, вписатися, це велике питання.
Бо, як показує досвід, при інсультах, треба значно більші суми.
В принципі, ці тарифи - це мінімум.
Ось, веноктамія -  видалення варикозної хвороби - 1800 гривень.
На ці гроші ви купите детралекс, еластичний бинт, але не прооперуєтеся.
Ми виконуємо втручання з використанням малоінвазивних методик.
Це коштує значно дорожче.
Я можу поки назвати лише мінуси цієї реформи.
Перший, реформа пропонує закриття 50% лікувальних закладів,
звільнення 50% медперсоналу.Тож якість медичної допомоги населенню погіршиться рівно удвічі.
Головний лікар Андрій Мусієнко - прихильник медичної реформи.
Але він, як і його підлеглі, не згоден ні з тарифами вартості медичних послуг,
ні з відсутністю чітко прописаних національних протоколів лікування тих же мозкових інсультів,
чи-то гриж, на яких спеціалізується лікарня.
Головний лікар вважає, що до того, як усі медзаклади зупинились
через епідемію коронавірусу в березні,
ні його лікарня, ні Національна служба здоров’я
не були на 100% готові до повноцінного старту реформи з 1 квітня.
Ми співпрацюємо. Але на сьогоднішній день ми працюємо в повному обсязі:
електронне направлення, електронний запис, отримання хворого тільки по направленню -
і тоді на це йде оплата НСЗУ…
А вона дала нам - Національна служба здоров’я -
на три місяці можливість глобального бюджету.
Ось вони вирахували по статистичним даним 18-го року, які були взяті за основу,
що ми приблизно лікували от-таку кількість людей в 18-тому році,
і вона дала нам глобальний бюджет місячний.
Головний лікар визнає, що глобального бюджету навряд чи б вистачило,
якби не доплати від КМДА за роботу в умовах пандемії.
Керівник сподівається, що в наступні два місяці
не доведеться скорочувати персонал чи навіть закривати цілі відділеня.
Скасувати реформу або призупинити.
Такими вимогами буквально завалили владу в Києві медики з інших регіонів.
Цю риторику частково підтримує і президент, і міністр охорони здоров’я Максим Степанов.
Можновладці виступають за переформатування медичної реформи
нібито з метою запобігти звільненню 50 000 медиків та закриттю майже 300 лікарень.
Призупинення чи переформатування реформи
категорично не підтримують у фонді "Пацієнти України",
який доклав багато зусиль задля її просування.
За словами виконавчої директорки Інни Іваненко,
невдоволення лікарів було прогнозоване –
не всі хочуть відходити від ще радянських принципів
функціонування системи охорони здоров’я.
А те, що противників реформи більшає, за словами Іваненко,
є результатом і частої зміни команд міністерства охорони здоров’я,
і відсутності діалогу чиновників з лікарями.
Те, що зараз відбувається і з виплатами лікарням,
що лікарі стали отримувати меншу зарплату…
Це все якби результат поганої комунікації з боку МОЗ.
І в принципі, ця ситуація, я б не сказала, що вона критична, і це те, що можна змінити,
Є і дуже хороші приклади, коли лікарі  задоволені,
коли до лікарень прийшло більше коштів,
ніж вони раніше отримували за медичною субвенцією.
Вони починають пацієнтам надавати дійсно безкоштовні послуги.
У Перинатальному центрі Києва, де приймають передчасні пологи
і допомагають малюкам набрати життєво необхідну вагу,
з острахом дивляться на нову дискусію навколо імовірної призупинки медреформи.
Аби в квітні 2020 року успішно впровадити медичну реформу,
тут готувалися майже два роки.
Лікарі і медсестри пройшли відповідні навчання,
ось, приміром, як зробити роботу зручнішою за допомогою електронних сервісів.
Центр зовсім не хоче повертатися у минуле,
коли їм не платили за кожного окремого пацієнта.
Тільки пройшов місяць реформи. От вже зараз ми отримали, наприклад,
аванс від НСЗУ, який 60%...нам дали.
Це вже ми отримали 6 млн 200 тис. грн, які ми вже маємо на розвиток.
Ми вже можемо використовувати ці гроші для кращого забезпечення пацієнтів,
як малих, так і мам, для надання їм медичної допомоги. І це тільки початок.
Лікарі центру сподіваються, що принцип "гроші йдуть за пацієнтом"
допоможе і зарплати суттєво підвищити,
і мати фінансову спроможність розвиватися і навчатися.
У 15-тій лікарні Києва натомість акцентують увагу на тому,
що не усі лікарні України раніше однаково фінансувалися і мають
усе необхідне сучасне обладнання задля впровадження реформи.
Лікар-хірург Сергій Симоненко каже, що у багатьох хірургів
і зараз немає усього необхідного обладнання.
Коли лише планувалася реформа,
скільки відсотків ВВП просили для організації цієї реформи? Здається, шість відсотків.
А дали втричі менше! Що можна зробити з тими грошима?!
Для того щоб реформа почала працювати, вони не змогли навіть третину необхідної суми виділити
Сімейна лікарка Наталя Шевчук розуміє побоювання колег зі вторинної ланки медицини.
Вона згадує початок реформи на первинній ланці,
коли сімейні лікарі теж думали, що і зарплати не зростатимуть,
і що держава нічим не забезпечить, і що ця реформа - так би мовити "повна фікція".
Вона показує нам свою амбулаторію,
де все є, аби надавати населенню гарантовані державою безкоштовні послуги,
і впевнено заявляє,
що лікарям краще працювати за формулою "гроші йдуть за пацієнтом".
Якщо він - фахівець, то в нього буде більше.
Так весь світ працює. Конкуренція.
Наталя Шевчук вважає, що лікарям треба активніше включатися в реформу.
Лікарка не очікує результатів реформи вторинної ланки медицини через місяць чи навіть три,
але впевнена, що ситуація на вторинній ланці покращиться, як і на первинній.
І зрештою лікарі отримуватимуть і гідні зарплати, і гідні умови праці.
А пацієнти - по-справжньому безкоштовні послуги, причому в усіх регіонах.
Адже саме для цього і була розпочата медреформа.